من تعتقد أنه وراء ذلك
الرجل الخطير ، لقد قلت ، من
تعتقد أنه وراء تلك اللعبة الخطيرة
، معظمهم من مستشاري الرئيس ترامب ،
وهذا شيء يمكن أن يخرج عن نطاق
السيطرة بسرعة كبيرة كما قلت إنه
جسم مائي صغير جدًا كما يبدو  أن
يكون هناك بعض الأشخاص في إدارة ترامب
الذين يضغطون
بقوة شديدة على
إلقاء اللوم على
إيران ، على سبيل المثال ، لإلقاء اللوم
على الميليشيات التابعة لإيران في هجوم على خط أنابيب مؤخرًا على المملكة العربية السعودية على الميليشيات
التابعة لإيران ، وهذا وضع
خطير للغاية ليس كذلك.  هذا كل
شيء هناك صندوق بارود يطرح عليك
سؤالاً كانت
المملكة العربية السعودية تقصف اليمن منذ
أربع سنوات وقتلت الكثير من
اليمنيين ولم يخلقوا شعورًا كافيًا
بالغضب في اليمن لعدم مطالبة إيران
بتحريض أي شخص على القيام بذلك ، فلماذا يفعلون ذلك.
نعزو هذا إلى إيران ، فهذه هي
عواقب اختياراتهم الخاطئة ،
لكنك ترى أننا في
منطقتنا لا يمكننا الانسحاب من
منطقتنا نحن  هنا ، من
جاء إلى منطقتنا والذي
جعل من الكلب الفارسي
ممرًا مائيًا مزدحمًا ، لم يكن نحن
، أعني أننا هناك فقط
لأن مياهنا تقع بجوار منزلنا
، وأمننا القومي ما هو  أنت
تقول إنك لا علاقة لك
بهجمات الناقلات أو أي شيء
يتعلق بذلك علنًا من قبل
ونعتقد أن الحوادث والحوادث من
هذا النوع لم تكن
حوادث من هذا النوع قد تحدث في
هذه المنطقة ليس بسبب
إيران  لأن سياسات الولايات المتحدة في هذه
المنطقة خلقت أعداء للولايات
المتحدة وسيواصل هؤلاء الأعداء
العمل بغض النظر عما تريده إيران